[Music]
in movies like carry blood comes by the
buckets perfecting that red gooey mess
took a long time and several different
recipes this is the story of how fake
movie blood is made
[Music]
back before film and TV a simple red
handkerchief on stage symbolized blood
but it was kind of boring so some
theatres up the ante by boiling a bug
known for its red pigment they used the
Cochin you bug because it creates red
dye when black and white movies came
along pigment in a matter so Hollywood
simplified things by using chocolate
syrup then in the 1930s when
black-and-white movies turned to color
Hollywood needed a new blood trick enter
John Tyne Gate a retired pharmacist
living in England he concocted the most
realistic looking blood yet called
Kensington gore using a combination of
mostly golden syrup food coloring
cornflour and water the most famous of
the blood recipes though comes from a
man named dick Smith he came up with
something on par with a Julia Child
recipe the catch his recipe was
poisonous one ingredient Kodak photo
flow is deadly when consumed so people
started replacing the poison with
creamer and other items that won't kill
you today a lot of the fake blood you
see on screen is computer-generated
but if you want to be legit it should be
poison or bugs
go ahead put it in your mouth go since
the first time it was announced to the
public that we are growing these there
are literally thousands of YouTube
videos of people eating Carolina Reapers
all over the world but I get a kick out
of most of them though it can be
unpleasant it's not a dangerous thing to
eat super hot peppers it's a chemical
reaction your brain perceives as heat so
you will stop doing it
[Music]
I'm smoking egg curry I created the
Carolina Reaper I got into breeding
peppers in college Minh just really was
interested in getting hotter and hotter
peppers once I tried them Guiness
awarded me the world record for the
hottest pepper in November of 2013 to
breed these things I crossed a ghost
pepper with a habanero and what came out
was this evil looking pepper it had
warts all over blisters they call them
and the first time I tasted it it
knocked me to my knees we get our
peppers tested regularly at Winthrop
University by dr. Calaway in the
chemistry lab all peppers are measured
by Scoville heat units which tell you
how hot the pepper is bell peppers have
zero Scoville heat units Tala Pino is
about five thousand a serrano 20,000 red
habaneros 200,000 ghost peppers 600,000
then you get to the Carolina Reaper
which is one point five six nine million
Scoville heat units the hottest thing in
the world when you eat the Carolina
Reaper the first sensation you get is
sweet and then all sudden the heat
starts going it's like burning burning
burning then the physiological stuff
starts your eyes will bloodshot they
just start tearing up and watering the
skin flushes you start breathing hard
but your metabolism starts raising up
some people say it's like eating molten
lava others will say it's like licking
the Sun to me it's like eating a
charcoal briquette and no matter what
you do you cannot get that burn out of
the back of your mouth I mean it's crazy
a lot of what I do is creative
expression you will look for traits in
one pepper and you look for traits in
another and you try to combine them and
keep both those traits there are other
breeders who are trying to break our
record but we've been holding unreleased
peppers in our back pocket that are
twice as hot or more than the Carolina
Reaper that we could submit to Guinness
at any time
my perception of what the limits are of
how hot you can breed a pepper has
changed as the science has progressed
over the years just tell me something
can't be done I'm gonna figure out a way
to do it in this curious Lagoon the
rivers may run red but rest assured its
water not blood although you could be
forgiven for confusing the two
[Music]
the red lagoon is located 12,000 feet
above sea level in an area of Chile so
remote that it wasn't even known by the
National Tourism office until 2009 and
maybe that's a good thing because much
like the pyramids in Egypt Blue Lagoon
is believed to be cursed legend says
that the waters are owned by the devil
himself and he is responsible for the
mysterious disappearances that have
occurred along the shores the thermal
temperatures of the water at a hundred
to 120 degrees stop even wild animals
from approaching it devils aside what
causes this blood-red water
well biologist studying the lagoon
recently traced it to algae growing in
the depths of the lake still much of
this lagoon remains a mystery a visit to
this place is a reminder there is still
much to marvel at on this planet during
the annual crab migration all of
Christmas Island is seeing red Christmas
Island located in the Pacific Ocean near
Australia is known for its warm tropical
climate throughout most of the year it's
endemic red crabs can be found on the
rainforest floor but each year in late
October the adult crowds begin a
spectacular mass migration from the
rainforest to the coast to breed and
release eggs into the sea this
synchronised breeding of about 40
million crabs takes over the tiny island
they take their cues from a unique
combination of weather and the movement
of the moon
as the reigns of the monsoon wet season
return they begin their journey the
crabs arrive at the coast where they dig
burrows for mating and then the females
release their eggs into the sea just as
the high tide from the new moon hits the
shore these crabs are so reliant on
these seasonal cues that if the wet
season doesn't arrive on time the crabs
will not spawn until the next lunar
month they make their migrations without
much care for Road rules or streets
which results in incredible and slightly
startling waves of red crabs moving
across the island this is wicked a red
panda at 10 years old wicked is a fully
grown male with the height of just over
2 feet or slightly larger than your
average house cat as cute as he is his
population has decreased dramatically
with less than 10,000 left in the wild
red panda renamed it is not closely
related to the giant panda but actually
closer to the raccoon family he loves to
eat bamboo but weren't turned down the
occasional bird insect or mammal for a
snack native to the eastern Himalayas
and southwestern China red pandas live
in trees and on nimble agile climbers
their reddish brown fur and bushy tails
camouflage them in their habitat from
predators like snow leopards besides
other animals humans pose a major threat
poaching and hunting them for their fur
the forest that they live in a shrinking
fast an estimates say that their
population has been cut in half in the
last 20 years this is the red panda
[Music]
this is commie a red ruffed lemur her
world is small and it's shrinking daily
the red ruffed lemur comes by its name
honestly it's covered in a brilliant
chestnut coat the rest of its body its
face hands belly and tail are a deep
black of the hundreds of species of
lemur in Madagascar the red ruffed lemur
is one of the most endangered found only
on a single peninsula in the northwest
of the island country the rainforest the
red ruffed lemur called home are also
highly valued for the beautiful rosewood
and ebony trees that grow there it's in
the canopy of these trees that you can
find these lemurs there they search for
fruit which makes up nearly their whole
diet their home forests are being
harvested at an alarming rate taking the
red ruffed lemurs chance of survival
with them conservationists estimate that
there are only three to five thousand
left in the wild
this is the red ruffed lemur
[Music]
you